my face is the front of shop my face is
the real shop front my shop is the fixer
front
I'm real when I shut my face
[Music]
hey guys it's Natalie welcome back to my
channel today I'm gonna do a makeup
tutorial as always but first storytime
storytime storytime
I just want to be upfront with you guys
and let you know that I've had some
facial surgery I'm always gonna be
honest with you guys about this kind of
thing because you mean so much to me
like you've been here with me since the
beginning and you've seen my story my
whole entire journey this journey I've
been on as a transgender woman you've
been with me on this whole journey this
is my truth and you've accepted the
truth of my journey as a really
vulnerable moment for me and you guys
are just as special because you've been
here for me throughout my whole
transgender your message of my journey
as a vulnerable servant of it's just
been so an explosion lighter and the
terms are guarantees America
[Music]
I think the main thing we've learned
together on this channel as that makeup
is a lot of fun but it's inner beauty
that really counts anyway let's talk
about plastic surgery I had a facial
feminization surgery on April 2nd so
about a month and a half ago what we
call a facial feminization surgery or
ffs is actually a series of different
procedures that some transgender women
choose to have to look more feminine so
what I had done is forehead contouring a
brow lift a rhinoplasty mandible
contouring a trachea shave you know what
let's just how the skull ad talk you
through it
a coronal incision was made a swatch the
cranial vote whence the skin of the
forehead was stripped away from the bone
a fragment of the supraorbital Ridge was
then chiseled away removed reshaped and
Rhea fixed thereby eliminating that
undesirable prominence of a robust brow
but oftimes distinguishes this skull of
the Chad a second decision was made with
warts the columellar of the nasal septum
facilitating the reconstruction of the
Interior cartilage and bone further
incisions were made between the gum and
cheek through which the mandible was
rasped and shaved down to a grace I'll
curvature a jaw and pointed chin thereby
delineating a facial silhouette
exhibiting that aspect which medical men
called Conte it all sounds pretty
gruesome when you describe it like that
but there's actually a very fine level
of technique and aesthetics involved my
plastic surgeon is an artist
the results are natural I don't look
like I've had a bunch of work done which
is good you know you at least want to
leave people wondering maybe she's born
with it maybe a surgeon killed her face
off and fixed her shitty skull here's it
before and after picture where you can
clearly see the difference T is the
exact medical terminology my brows on
fleek
my nose is no longer busted the house my
jaw snatched and my Adam's apple is
cancelled wasn't it always really Eve's
Apple may be Satan's Apple I think I
still look like myself it's not a new
face we're talking about millimeters of
bone here but to have all that done was
well it costs a lot of money the
anticipation was a terror like I've
never known the pain was
rabble and the recovery took more than a
month in fact I still have some swelling
in my jowls cowls there's a nice
feminine sounding word love that the
standard YouTube tea girl thing to do of
course would have been to vlog the whole
journey
storytime my facial surgery experience
my ffs journey and post constant social
media updates about it and I am grateful
to the trans woman who have done that
because it was really helpful to me to
be able to watch those vlogs in advance
and know what I was getting myself into
but I decided not to post about the
surgery because I wanted privacy for the
recovery and to just take some time to
get to feel at home with the results
before subjecting myself to the vicious
things they say about me and the
tabloids you know I think I've been kind
of psychologically damaged by reading
for years the things people say about my
appearance online and I'm not even
talking about the haters like at this
point I can mostly brush them off but
for instance about a year ago I was
reading through a transgender subreddit
and some trans woman was ionizing about
her appearance and someone offered the
encouragement you know you can still
look hot even if you don't pass just
look at contra points oh like a dagger
to the horror the unintentional shade of
it all
so the past six weeks have been at times
difficult and lonely but I did manage to
keep my mug off social media for long
enough that I'm as ready as I'm ever
going to be for the commentary of the
Internet so bring it on you jackals you
vultures you Goblin swine well I was
lying around bandaged and bored I did
have a lot of time to think and what
I've been thinking about is probably the
same thing you're wondering right now
which is why would someone do what I
just did
why would I spend so much time and money
and go through so much anxiety and pain
just to change a few millimeters of bone
isn't this all just extravagant vanity
some narcissistic symptom of phones but
too much well I feel like there's a lot
of pressure on me to say that in fact
this wasn't cosmetic surgery at all
usually trans people say that surgery is
like facial feminization top surgery
general reassignment and so on served
the sole purpose of alleviating gender
dysphoria this discomfort we feel with
the mismatch between our bodies and our
gender identity so what I'm supposed to
say is that my surgery was a medically
necessary reconstructive procedure
needed to make my testosterone whether
facial bones match the five-foot-two
happy baby bouncy bio girl I truly am
inside thereby alleviating my dysphoria
helping me safely blend into society and
preventing a five-alarm psychiatric
meltdown and there is definitely truth
to that it's certainly the argument I
intend to make when I write this off as
a medical expense on my taxes if you're
an IRS auditor please stop this video
now and insert the next floppy disk into
your CD Drive but hypothetically
speaking I think the reality might not
be quite as simple how sharp is the line
separating gender dysphoria from the
other kinds of body image dysphoria that
drives cisgender people to get cosmetic
surgery all the time last year when I
used to foolishly tweet things of
substance I tweeted that I wanted to get
ffs and some trans people responded
telling me that I was suffering from
internalized transphobia and
self-loathing they compared it to East
Asian people getting double eyelid
surgery or so-called ethnic rhinoplasty
which they say are motivated by
internalized racism and Western beauty
standards I think that's a pretty weak
analogy and telling a trans person to
just learn to accept the way they look
can actually be kind of transphobic
because a big part of what it even means
to be trans at least for me
the desire to look more female but I
also think trans people often talk like
gender dysphoria is this intrinsic
personal experience that's always 100%
valid and never has anything at all to
do with the external pressure of beauty
standards but in fact gender dysphoria
is not sealed away in a vacuum away from
the influence of societal ideals and
norms early in my transition some of my
worst dysphoria was about body hair so I
had full body laser hair removal and now
I'm smoother than a cisgender boiled egg
but where does the idea that women don't
have body hair come from isn't that just
an arbitrary grooming custom a lot of
this is women I know don't so much as a
shave their legs so maybe I'm not even
trying to look like a sis woman maybe
I'm simply doing everything I can to
avoid looking like the caricature of a
knuckly hairy bird mannish trans woman
with which society has terrorized me to
my core is this gender dysphoria or is
it internalized transphobia or is it
simply a cosmetic preference when I try
to psychoanalyze myself I find that my
desire is to look female to look
feminine and to look beautiful are not
exactly the same but they're woven
together so tightly that it's kind of
difficult to untangle them and the
opposite is also true
that for me feeling mannish or dysphoric
usually goes along with feeling ugly I
don't have a lot of days where I walk
out the house thinking well I'm giving
femme queen realness but apart from that
I look like absolute [ __ ] of course
there are qualities that make you look
female that aren't necessarily
attractive like cellulite or flabby arms
which are super fish but aren't deemed
beautiful by society the truth is I
don't just want to look female I want to
be beautiful desperately God will do
anything
and evening in this video I want to
explore why I'm so obsessed with being
beautiful and why it seems like a lot of
people who live in a society we're so
obsessed
is it phones I know you're supposed to
pretend that you don't care about being
beautiful or that you're not trying but
guys it's the only thing I care about
and I've never tried so hard anything of
course I do feel guilty about being so
obsessed with it because there is this
idea that caring about beauty makes you
shallow or vain you know smart people
aren't supposed to care about beauty and
I've always been categorized as a smart
person by people around me some of that
is when you're raised like I was as a
middle-class white boy with no athletic
talent parents and teachers treat you
like a [ __ ] genius
like Einstein nutted a load in Mozart's
Buzzi and Mozart shot you out while he
was getting a rusty trombone from
Vincent van Gogh it inspired his famous
painting starfish Knight but even among
women caring about beauty is often
frowned upon I feel like an alien
species when I hang out with women in
academia and I know a few because I once
got half a PhD before dropping out to
become a what do you call someone who
makes videos a cam girl most female grad
students and professors I know don't
wear makeup to them the idea of
earnestly putting on press-on nails or
false eyelashes is inconceivable like
maybe on Halloween now part of that is
that women in male-dominated fields
sometimes feel like they have to present
more masculine to be taken seriously
because of this prejudice that
beautified femininity equals frivolous
but another part is clearly some kind of
not like other girls weird flux which
okay fine whatever I'm not going to
judge another woman for the way she
cooks with a society that pressures
women to be beautiful while
simultaneously belittling them for
caring about it I guess my way of coping
is this tacky heteronormative and
tragically sincere aspiration to some
kind of post ironic feminine beauty why
am I like this
well part of it is vindictive
transsexualism pure and simple to all
the people who have ever called me a man
I want to say [ __ ] you by looking like
the undeniable visual archetype of a
woman which is a beautiful feminine
woman who's wearing six hundred thousand
sequins their biological sequence
oh that is some an Samaras right there
inside
[Music]
another factor is this shitty website
I'm a professional YouTube influencer
forgive me father and I'm on camera all
the time I edit my own videos so I spend
upwards of 60 hours a month staring at
my own face on a screen now you try
doing that and see what kind of [ __ ]
up complex you develop plus I compare
myself to other women who make videos a
lot of the trans women on YouTube are so
young and so beautiful it makes me want
to throw up and in comparison for a long
time I felt like this
shabby aging transvestite just this
feral cat wandering the aisles of the
liquor store so I'm insecure I'm
compensating for that whole mess but I
honestly don't present the beautiful
people I really just stand the hell out
of them I follow this woman on YouTube
and I want to be just like her mom her
name is named Jefferson Starr her name
is Lady Jayne MacLean senior on Nicole
Bethany Jade tutorials tatyana petrov
NatWest Ricola and of course my queen
and perfect goddess human sty Stan and
whose portrait I've painted hundreds of
times so there's maybe some extra
intensity for me but I think it's
actually pretty normal to want to be
beautiful I think you even grad students
want to be beautiful they just want to
do it in that Becky kind of way will you
scoff at anything glam or artificial and
it's not just women who care about
beauty either I mean gay men in LA I've
always been getting cosmetic surgery but
now even the straights are doing it in
cells are completely obsessed with the
defects of their personal appearance and
the ones who are completely black pilled
are obsessed with plastic surgery the in
cell news speak word for beauty is looks
maxing because of course they have to go
about this in the most heterosexual
possible way it is imperative in from
the skin max regimen in order to
maximize looks money status and secure
access to females oh my god calm Dion
not every sentence out of your mouth has
to be worded like a dispatch to the
police commissioner yes they actually
call skin care skin max James Charles I
know you're having a hard month but I've
got a business idea that's gonna turn
this thing around for you here's a plan
you're gonna create a new line of
skincare products called Chad glow bribe
Beauty pie to send its fans to the promo
video hi sister cells and send me a
check in the mail you're welcome if you
read looks max forums they're filled
with discussions of brow Ridge implants
chin implants mandible implants it a
must need
remark that the skull of the Chad
exhibited a jawbone most robust it's
literally facial masculinization surgery
so everyone's obsessed with the bones
everyone's obsessed with beauty whether
man or woman cysts or trans gay or gamer
maybe lesbians are just straight chillin
well everyone else has completely lost
their minds but why why do we care so
much
but within cells by their own account
the only reason they care is they think
that looks maxing will make females have
sex with them and I think of that will
make their lives feel meaningful which
it will not so in cells are cancelled
now what about women what's our deal
what's our sitch
what's our vibe what's our veg well man
seem to think that women are like
inverted in cells that we care about
beauty and wear makeup fake up because
we're trying to attract men
my daddy Don Juan on Vice news last year
and said that women wear makeup because
they're trying to stimulate male sexual
arousal and because evolution now there
is a go being bratty I gotta say this is
maybe 10% true and 90% false for one
thing straight men don't like makeup at
least they don't think they do here's a
chart I made illustrating what every
straight man in the world thinks about
makeup yes I asked all of them if you
wear no makeup they think you look
diseased and I actually do look diseased
when I don't wear makeup so fair enough
if you were a natural makeup you know a
little concealer or mascara maybe a nude
lip they think you're not wearing any
makeup and they like it if you wear a
county makeup colorful eye shadow heavy
contouring overdrawn lips they think
it's dumb and they hate it of course I'm
generalizing hashtag not all daddy
Thomas but if women really wore may go
to attract man then you'd expect that
they'd stop wearing it when there are no
men around but that doesn't happen about
a month ago there was that video going
around of a woman showing how to make a
jailhouse makeup mixing deodorant and
magazine inked make eyeshadow using
kool-aid and Vaseline to make a lipstick
there's not a lot of man in women's
prison but women are still performing
incredible feats of ingenuity and
resourcefulness just to wear makeup so
maybe women are using makeup to express
their individuality and femininity you
know things that Prison tries to take
away from you kind of makes sense
there's a refinery29 documentary about
prison cosmetology and also sexual
exploitation yikes in which of
inmate describes how women would engage
in sexual bartering with male guards
just to get makeup if a girl's
performing sexual favors from an officer
he would bring her in colored pencils
lipgloss things like that that's right
women are a sucking dick so they can put
on makeup not the other way around
honestly if all the men died tomorrow
off I definitely keep wearing makeup in
fact I might wear more and I'm not just
saying that cuz I'm trying to win
feminist points or anything like do I
want to attract man yes of course I do
do I want to a chart to women I guess I
don't really think about it isn't it
safer to just secretly fall in love with
them while quietly dying inside whatever
it's fine
I want to attract a non-binary people to
of course but right now you guys are
kind of getting in the way of my crudely
stereotyping people based on gender so
how dare you the point is when I think
about my appearance wanting to attract
people to have sex with is not the main
thing going through my head what is
going through my head
I guess I just want to feel beautiful I
want to see myself in the mirror and
think I look snotch is that a crime I
don't feel pretty very often I'd say it
happens about once a month I'm having a
good skin day I do my makeup just right
like a listen with setting spray and
that happens a tingle goes up my spine
I am Botticelli I am van Gogh I have
created Beauty I'm a girl and then it's
over that's it for a month you really
want to look in the mirror I can't
actually tell whether I'm pretty or not
like with other people I can just look
at them and instantly make a judgement
about it but with myself I have to just
guess it's the same as being a trans
person trying to figure out whether you
pass would you clock me I'd clock me I'd
[ __ ] me - I don't give a [ __ ] get out of
my room mom it doesn't work like that
for me
I have to rely on other people's
feedback of course the problem with
other people's feedback is that people
are liars
you look great on especially when those
people are your fans
what's the house Queen some of my throat
mother I'll die for you oh my god or
when they're your haters
you're disgusting a giant collarbone
Nazi was a man out of thousand paces I
guess I'll never know whether I'm pretty
or not but I can estimate like I have
figured out that I'm too pretty for
Twitter but I'm not sure yet if I'm
pretty enough for Instagram it's hard
being a six I have been dipping my toes
in the Instagram water before my surgery
I got into a pretty good rhythm of
posting my shitty little makeup looks
and what I find an addictive about it is
this constant flow of positive comments
from other people even though I know
it's mostly flattery you invented beauty
perfect angel choke me Mommy every time
I could a comment like that I'm
perfectly aware that it's wild
exaggeration fueled by parasocial
delusions but I still get a head of
dopamine in my biologically female brain
and the intoxicating thing about
Instagram is that the embellishment of
the truth is a two-way street thanks to
the miracle of facetune yes we finally
get to talk about the phones see it's a
black mirror because it's a window into
the darkness of the human soul got it
should I explain it again bones live in
a society facetune is an app that lets
you fix all the problems
with your face so here's an unedited pre
ffs picture of me what I would do in
face tune is smooth out the complexion
shrink the nose a little bring the jaw
in and use the vibrance tool to make the
eyeshadow pop it's really no more
drastic than the kinds of photo
doctoring people have been doing since
the invention of photography what's
changed is that now everyone is doing it
to their own photos every day and I've
noticed that when I'm in the habit of
editing my flaws out of pictures what I
look at an unedited picture of myself or
I look in the mirror my eyes go straight
to the flaws
why are my pores so big why aren't
medical scientists doing something to
stop Venice is this really a good use of
my mental energy here comes that guilt
again instead of worrying about my pores
shouldn't I be helping stop the
impending climate catastrophe that it's
gonna destroy the planet if we don't
change the economy in like 12 years she
I guess it's 11 years now it's just hard
to focus on climate change when there's
so much else on my mind
he's just so cute I guess I just rather
think about the aesthetic and the
apocalypse and that's the darkness why
is my neck like two decades older than
the rest of my skin 20 Botox yeah should
I get a facelift these are the questions
that will no doubt defined the next
couple decades of my life as if it
wasn't bad enough to have to go through
a second adolescence on camera I also
have to deal with aging and thus the
ritual of skincare products here's my
daytime routine so first I'm gonna mix
the Dermalogica exfoliator with the
cleansing gel and just massage my face
none of this is sponsored by the way
this is just me supporting corporations
out of the kindness of my heart now if
I'm not running late for something I
will do a face mask but if I'm out of
bed it's because I'm running late for
something so I've never done a face mask
now I'm gonna use a toner which is very
important now a lot of people don't know
what a toner does but look at tones okay
do you want your face to be unknown next
I'm gonna spray expensive Korean yeast
directly into my eyes I use this because
it's actually a lot cheaper than the
Japanese yeast so you're really losing
money if you don't buy it
think of the savings now I'm gonna mix a
pump of hyaluronic acid with a couple
spritzes of organic Bulgarian rose water
you can almost smell the Bulgarian rose
fields it's enchanting it's like I'm
there there's not enough serum in the
world for this neck leather I use this
moisturizer because Gigi gorgeous told
me to and I do everything Gigi says
I know it seems like a lot of products
but once you get locked into a serious
skincare collection the tendency is to
push it as far as you can and I feel
like I'm forgetting something a
sunscreen I'm not really sure what this
does we can probably skip it and I'm
just gonna finish it all off with some
more expensive mist yes god I love a
good facial I am so [ __ ] wet right
now so after all these products does my
skin look clearer younger more toned
well it's hard to say for sure but it
certainly is moist this is the part
where I usually just stare at my own
face for ten minutes and contemplate the
futility of my struggle against the
ravages of time
I'm fine that's fits fine this is fine
it's fine
[Music]
vanitas Vanette heart'll @ omnia vanitas
for dust thou art and unto dust shalt
thou return
leastwise i shall bequeath a female
skull so isn't beauty supposed to be fun
I'm not having fun right now why am I
not having fun I guess I just don't feel
beautiful and I know a lot of people
think I'm pretty and I know a lot of
other people have it worse than me and I
know I should be grateful and I know I'm
privileged to be able to get plastic
surgery and I know I shouldn't care so
much about this in the first place
but the truth is that this just eats
away at me and I'm losing a lot of time
and life to this pain I've been kind of
depressed to this past month and I think
part of it is that on a subconscious
level I think I was hoping that surgery
would completely change my self-image
and make me like myself but it really
hasn't I mean I'm happy with the results
I'd do it all again but I still feel the
way I felt before you have to keep in
mind that surgery fixes very specific
problems like the Adam's apple problem
or the way my forehead looks in profile
problem but it's really not a solution
to deep psychological issues I still
don't feel beautiful and I need to face
the fact that I'm never going to feel
beautiful unless I change the way I
think because I'm trapped in a doom
spiral over here and if I'm ever gonna
get out I think I need to start by
forgiving myself for wanting to be
beautiful there's lots of reasons to
want to be beautiful besides being a
shallow and vain for one beauty is
associated with youth it's a symbol of
life of defiance of death that's a
profound thing to be concerned about see
I'm not a bimbo I'm a poet beauty is
also associated with moral worth the
beautiful princess versus the evil hag
there's studies showing that
conventionally attractive people are
more likely to be assumed to be happy
healthy and trustworthy they're more
likely to be hired so it's not just
about Instagram likes this is serious
stuff and we the woke we're all aware of
this we know that beauty is power that
beauty is political
we know that beauty standards come from
the people with privilege in an unequal
Society we know it's unjust that being
light-skinned assists able-bodied or
thin is considered more attractive than
being dark-skinned trans disabled or 5
we know that female beauty matters so
much because patriarchy we know that our
obsession with beauty is being provoked
by advertising the cosmetic industry and
beauty influencers who are trying to
sell as products we know we know we know
all this because we've all been sitting
around critiquing it for decades
because that's what leftists do we
critique things we are finely tuned
detectors of racism sexism ableism
fatphobia transphobia and capitalism
Ronnie Mack we notice an injustice we
problematize it we critique it and then
we cancel it but what's next when we're
done critiquing things what are we
supposed to do because I'm aware that
conventional beauty standards are a
racist sexist ablest fad phobic
transphobic social construct designed to
preserve power relations and sell
products but does that awareness mean I
desire any less to be conventionally
beautiful well no I want am more than
ever the problem is that the
intellectual exercise of critiquing
things doesn't usually affect my desires
very much so what am I supposed to do
sit here in silent contemplation until
my desires finally align themselves with
the interests of the International
proletarian revolution
oh [ __ ] the revolution I want to be a
pretty rich girl I don't want to be
content to be GG gorgeous fighting
fascists on YouTube was an idea I came
up with when I was a male alcoholic
unfortunately America needs the Contra
points right now more than it needs a
thirty-year-old GG gorges impersonator
so I guess I'm stuck with it maybe it's
for the best
critiquing a society may not change our
desires but it can motivate us to change
society and changing society can change
our desires so how do we change society
revolution
well sure revolution depending on what
happens in 2020 I'll think of grabbing a
brick myself but failing that I
thinks there are ways we can work to
loosen the grip of restrictive beauty
standards without the futility of trying
to stop caring how we look
I do think representation matters and I
think having a visible Beauty icons who
are dark-skinned or trans or gender
non-conforming or disabled or fat or
over 35 or influencers makes a big
difference
Beauty standards are social constructs
and social constructs can change that's
why it's so important to recognize that
influencers are just as valid as other
celebrities for the promise changing
society is that it takes a long time in
this video is almost over where I can
see an escape from my particular doom
spiral is in style as an alternative
ideal to beauty you can be stylish at
any age you can be stylish whether you
pass or not style is a way of
cultivating a personal aesthetic that
you have complete control over it's like
art and that originality
is a virtue style is an individual
aesthetic unlike the collective
aesthetic of beauty standards as the
poet Wordsworth said about artistic
appreciation every author as far as he
is great and at the same time original
has had the task of creating the taste
by which he is to be enjoyed so even if
you don't conform to conventional beauty
standards through the power of original
style you can create the taste by which
your unique beauty is to be appreciated
society may frown upon us six-foot
[ __ ] but if I know I'm dressed well
or my makeup is smudged I can easily
abide any comment and he stare I can be
misgendered a Dairy Queen for all I care
it does not matter I can strut with
confidence because I am basking in the
regal knowledge of my own aesthetic
superiority bow before me peasants I
proclaim to the drive-through window for
I am serving a lurk so I guess that's
the solution I can't believe I
single-handedly added capitalism now
does that mean I'm not gonna get a lot
of expensive plastic surgery [ __ ] no
what do you people think I am some kind
of transgender mother Teresa god damned
the audacity of you people the hubris
look I need plastic surgery because I
have no style in fact after the month
had you should be grateful I'm wearing
clothes at all so that's it for me I
guess I have nothing but the decay of
time and age to look forward to I guess
I'll just have to find my self-worth and
cultivating kindness intelligence and
inner beauty you gross
[Music]
I'm drooling all over myself because my
jaw is still numb from the surgery left
I